one day he's performing a tribute to
Little Richard at the Beatty Awards
Little Richard just didn't sing a song
he created this art form that was born
out of it was a frenetic energy
he was extra before we knew the
definition of oh you extra and you
posted it on Instagram and it just like
I was in my house it's a little daunting
you're on an award show with all these
amazing black performers Beyonce has
four nominations and will receive the
Humanitarian Award
Liz owes up for four awards and Drake
leaves the nominations with six the
show's host Amanda seals told us he's
not nervous so I get to host the show
and I don't got to do a red carpet I
don't got to talk to nobody so I'm not
ripping it off
I love innovation I love creativity and
that's what this show really is like
leaning into it's gonna be a smorgasbord
you know it's gonna be a potpourri of
performances but I think that's what
speaks to black music right then the BT
org is giving you all different flavors
from gospel to soul to hip hop this is a
star Asante black and miles Brown from
blackish are both up for the young stars
award it's a great category right you
got Marseille Myles storm this really is
like the foundation of the future so
it's good to see a category like this
with you all in it I wonder if what
we're gonna be doing in ten years and
looking bagging like I'm not late it
together you know well everyone is
asking for change we're looking to
younger generations so what can your
generation you how do you use your voice
to aid to the movement I would want to
be telling my generation to be open to
learn about what's going on right now
and to be open to learn about the past
because I don't want to have to you know
be doing marches about this in you know
in the future
[Music]